hello and welcome to this video en tanga
I am tango singapore singapore so the
Royal Exchange I have never played this
person here on the ICC and the reason is
it's a brand new account well not Brenda
we spray in August but it's a very
infrequently used account so we forget
this ending here i'm not a huge expert
so that will seem this is not something
that i ever played with black so in some
cases within the e4 e5 university I know
things because of my experience from
them through the black side but this is
not one of them so then what's going on
here can I I wonder about night h4 and
then f3 maybe hmm I that Miss places the
night I still would like to hmm probably
still strange but I'm kind of reluctant
to let him take there all the time maybe
I can play age three he goes back one
entirely so I go here or f3 f3 doesn't
really every I have no squares anymore
so this for potential return
my pawn structure is good but the rest
is not yeah well the rest is not is a
bit strong but my pieces don't really do
that well probably on this position is
roughly equal but there is my my feeling
yeah I wanted to get this back anyway so
let's do it I wonder what he's up to
with the knife down whoa I was thinking
at I'm threatening 95 years to teach
Utley it seems he didn't feel like that
okay so his Bishop past is gone and
maybe let's fix this on a dark square in
general i'm pretty happy about trading
with the better structure here
yeah he wants to provoke the Moose III I
don't I don't think I'm complying him I
gave three and then night c4 ok so it
puts it over there huh I have no idea
where he is going with this I could
check it doesn't do much do I don't
quite get it don't quite get this idea
at 92 94 se try to do something like
that
hmm didn't have that on the radar really
oh ok is it dangerous ok let's take your
first totally probably should be done
anyway if I take his [ __ ] c6 potentially
this is am an issue I can also place you
three here by the way taketake c3 maybe
yeah why not if he can see for I take me
for and I have and I have Luke c1c for
coming on that it looks good unless I'm
blundering it unless a blundering stuff
might be here that some night you ok all
stuff like that but but
I should get you the a pawn somehow
Bishop c5 maybe as a move trencher and
92 for so let's do this I wonder Bishop
c5 Knight f6 it was rupee 8 done
Bishop g5 I can claim this is an
interesting move actually I mean this is
a Tribble pawn in a king of porn ending
for example I could be winning with the
form against 3 i'm missing obvious moves
here that's not good wow I totally
missed this roof shoot time morning
cakes I should have seen the move I mean
I'm not saying I'm not really sure about
it if it is fantastic or anything but I
should have seen at and kind of had some
kind of idea against it but I didn't so
it takes this
that looks wrong yeah maybe it's not
wrong I don't know looks a bit passive
the smooth but mean I'm having the
better corn structure here and
potentially also a good minor piece
okay ah wow I didn't see that I just
blended the e4 pawn oh my god i really
should stop playing today giving away
all those games him from a kiddy better
and out of this oh my god check and now
i'm winning again check check gain draw
yeah i just need a couple of seconds wow
I blender before in the ending oh my god
okay so yeah this is roughly roughly
theory it certainly looks totally normal
at least um okay so i knew it like this
i was very surprised that you allowed 95
I think this is probably a strategic
strategic mistake give me the bishop
pair or wrong give up on the bishop and
this position is certainly somewhat
better for white and it's more or less
confirmed by what the engine is
suggesting
so here I should plot I should place III
at some point yes III just wins why
didn't I do that what did I do this one
after which he still had this this b5 of
55 business I am not playing well I just
see three as this basically game over
here take a 5-4 nothing and this night
is totally misplaced here so after after
this it's it's still somewhat
interesting okay funny ending I didn't
see Bishop to rook g6 at all I mean just
not good and now we get this ending cat
and plunder you for later really crazy
cap I mean it should be a quite
borderline ending i think the engine
gives shoes thinks it's a draw possible
possible but why do I give a very for
it's just just to read I just I just
didn't see it I mean I know it sounds
funny of it yeah this ending a black
should win doctor here can he somehow
somehow gave me this cap and this is
winning but it takes moves to cat to get
in there kim reasonably close at least
yeah it's just here a couple of moves to
checkmate but still here like five moves
or so and you did like one or two more
one or two more seconds yeah i'm giving
away too many easy easy points here
currently ok guys thanks for watching